euh comment ne pas avoir une provocation
à la fois vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine mais
aussi de la communauté internationale de
la part de Vladimir Poutine en se
rendant à Mario Paul Mario Paul une
ville une ville martyre qui a été qui
est occupée depuis le mois de mai
dernier par l'armée russe Mario Paul ou
des crimes de guerre ont été commis je
pense évidemment en bombardement du
théâtre dans lequel c'était réfugié des
centaines de personnes il y a eu au
moins 600 personnes mortes dans ce dans
ce dans cet abri
anti-aérien qui a été bombardé par les
forces russes donc évidemment une
provocation et ce qui est intéressant
aussi que c'est que cette visite si elle
est avérée elle intervient un moment au
moment où on voit beaucoup dans les
médias russe yefghani privé du groupe de
mercenaires Wagner et là on sait
évidemment que qu'il y a une rivalité
entre entre les deux hommes donc cette
visite symbolique à plus d'un titre